طعا لعلك سمعت الى ما قاله مراسلنا الياس
انه هذه القوات التي يتم سحب ويتم احلل
قوات اخرى مكانها لكن سحب هذه الكتيبه
تحديدا الكتيبه 13 التي قتل قائدها ثم قتل
قائدها بعد ذلك ثم قتل منها
41 ما الدلاله التي تعطيها تعطيها وما اثر
ذلك على الروح المعنويه ل الجنود
الموجودين في غزه من جانب الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ايه تمام اخي زين دعني واياك
نستعرض ما جرى بالامس وانا على
فضائيتين في حي الشجاعيه وحينها تحدثت انا
وقلت يقصف بصفتي ضابط مدفعيه وصواريخ
بصفتي قائد مدفعيه وصواريخ ومشاهدتي لهذا
الستار الدخاني هذا يعني انه هناك انسحاب
ل للجيش الاسرائيلي يريد تغطيته وان هناك
خسائر كبيره في صفوف هذا الجيش يريد
تغطيتها فبالتالي يعني انا بتقديري وكان
وكان هناك يعني شبه تاكيد بان هذه الكتيبه
التي كانت متواجده في في في الشجاعيه هي
التي خاضت هذه المعركه والتي خسرت عددا
كبيرا والتي فشلت في تحقيق اهدافها هذا من
جانب من جانب اخر اخي زين معروف عن
الوحدات العسكريه يكون فيها وحده
استخبارات ومن مهامها من مهام وحده
الاستخبارات هذه انها تجمع معلومات عن
الروح المعنويه والقتاليه عند الجنود اذا
ما شعر القيادات ان هناك تدني في الروح
المعنويه
والقتاليه وبالتزامن مع خسارتها في
الميدان سواء كان بالارواح او كان
بالمعدات القتاليه دبابات واليات او عدم
تحقيق الاهداف هذا يؤدي الى ه اذا يعني
انسحاب انسحاب طوعي للكتيبه كما جرى في
حادثه سابقه في الشمال كان هناك انسحاب
لوحدات انسحبت بمعنى انها هربت هربت من
الميدان فبالتالي حتى لا تصل هذه الكتيبه
13 التي قتل قائدها وقتل ضابط كبير اخر
فيها وقتل عدد كبير كما قال الياس قبل
قليل حتى لا تصل الى مرح مله الهروب او
الانسحاب الاجباري من الميدان انا اعتقد
تم سحب هذه الكتيبه والا ما معنى ان تسحب
كتيبه من اللواء يعني عاده اذا ما ارادوا
اعاده تنشيط واعاده تنظيم للواء يسحب
اللواء ويستبدل بلواء اخر كامل حتى يقاتل
مع بعضه البعض ووحدات منسجمه مع بعضها
البعض اما ان تسحب كتيبه بحد ذاتها انا
اعتقد هي ضربه للواء اعاده الاحلال للقوات
يصحبه قنابل
دخان هذا بالامس كان اه هذا بالامس نعم
صحيح يعني اذا كنت انت تعيد انتشار او تحل
قوات محل قوات هل في هذه
الحاله يجري ذلك باطلاق قنابل الدخان كما
حدث
بالامس بالتاكيد لانه هم يريدون ان ان
يعملوا المنطقه لا يريدوا للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه ان تلاحق
سده الواء سده الواء